Part-flattened after a car loaded with explosives
passed through a military checkpoint and detonated
inside the compound.
Officials say several gunmen then stormed
the base -- opening fire at soldiers, before
being gunned down themselves.
It was around six o'clock.
There was a very big explosion.
I thought there had been an earthquake.
It was very strong.
It's the latest in what has become near-daily
assaults by the Taliban -- who have been stepping
up their attacks on government facilities
in recent months -- undeterred by the harsh
winter.
This time, the Taliban were able to breach
the compound's security barriers, by using
a vehicle they had captured from the Afghan
military.
Some of the injured were taken to local hospitals
for treatment.
More serious cases were sent some 50 kilometres
away to the capital, Kabul.
The government is facing accusations that
it's hiding the true death toll -- so as to
avoid further worsening morale among Afghanistan's
already-shattered security forces.